aujourd'hui hors elana créateur du blog
france chili bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france c'est un grand
moment que vit en ce moment même le
chili c'est un moment sans doute
historique et certains disent que c'est
l'aboutissement de ce qui a commencé les
18 octobre 2010 nec avec la révolte
sociale qui s'est vue arrêté par par la
pandémie
c'est un un moment inédit dans
l'histoire du jury
le choix des électeurs et capitale
puisque ce sont eux qui seront donc
chargés d'écrire la nouvelle
constitution
à quoi pourrait ressembler cette
assemblée une assemblée et qui se veut
citoyenne et paritaire alors
effectivement il y a il ya ces deux
conditions là d'une part et il sert à
paritaire donc hommes et femmes à
égalité dans le nombre des aiguilles à
5,55 et constituant qui vont être élus
et est aussi c'est la première fois
qu'il y aura une partie une
représentation des peuples originaires
donc c'est tout nouveau même au niveau
mondial
la constitution c'était l'une des
revendications issues du plus grand
soulèvement social des dernières
décennies en octobre 2019 pour réclamer
une société plus égalitaire concrètement
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait retrouver dans
la prochaine constitution chilienne
qu'est ce qui est attendu par la
population alors je pense pas qu'il
s'agit des airs et réécrire la
constitution justement c'est cesser
complètement partir de d'autres choses
effacer la constitution écrite sous la
dictature du général pinochet et au
niveau des des revendications que les
chiliens la grande majorité des chiliens
a approuvé il ya quelques mois dans le
plébiscite qui est le lieu où presque
80% de la population à voter pour
justement avoir une nouvelle
constitution la rédaction d'une nouvelle
constitution
il y a notamment la santé et l'accès à
la santé et l'éducation c'est les deux
les deux facteurs qui importe le plus
aux gens en sachant que les systèmes
économique est fondé sur un système des
retraites privatif et qui qui qui est au
coeur de toutes les inégalités qui a
obéi et bien c'est d'entrer je crois
dans l'état providence qu'est-ce que
cela signifie
bah c'est à dire que le système
économique qui a été mis en place au
chili des puits depuis 30 ans et qui a
été
mis en place sous la dictature de
pinochet et pour celui une fois qu'est
la démocratie est arrivé par tous les
partis de gauche et de droite qui se
sont succédé au pouvoir et l'état l'état
dans la constitution actuelle du feeling
n'existait pas et le on a vu cette
absence de l'état avec la pandémie qui a
qui est vraiment fini par faire éclore
le système il était mis en place un
outil liquidée au bout du bout de d'un
cycle de cette nouvelle constitution
pourrait découler des réformes sociales
c'est ça l'objectif final c'est ce
qu'attend le chignon bas ces dix
premiers au monde c'est difficile à
savoir qu'ils prêtent les résultats
parce que c'était cette élection
premièrement il ya quatre élections le
même jour il ya quatre formulaire qui
sont choisis il ya les élections de mer
il ya une élection de conseillers il ya
les élections des gouverneurs qui est la
première fois que les gouverneurs des
régions pour être élu et non pas choisi
par le président et en plus de ça il ya
les 155 constituant rédiger la nouvelle
c'est une élection très très très
complexe et on ne sait pas trop ce qui
peut se passer
il faut pas oublier que que cette
élection là les les 155 constituants qui
vont être élus ce soir vers minuit on va
savoir
et il faut qu'il y ait deux tiers des
ses 155 et élus qui vont rédiger devons
avoir la tâche de rédiger la nouvelle
constitution et il faut avoir un accord
des deux tiers pour que ça puisse
avancer et ils n'auront que 12
moi pour maximum pour rédiger cette
constitution est ce que vous avez une
idée de la mobilisation
ces deux derniers jours puisque le
scrutin a commencé hier et se poursuit
donc sa dimanche quelle est la
mobilisation est ce que c'est un scrutin
qui attire les chignons moi je pense que
je pense que oui alors il faut savoir
que les votes au chili n'est pas
obligatoire
c'était l'une des mesures qui ont été
prises sous la dictature de pinochet et
il ya 50% du pays qui qui qui va qui va
aux urnes
donc je crois que c'est le problème
c'est que un des problèmes c'est la
complexité de l'élection que vous voyez
dans les images qu'elle vous passé il ya
quatre bulletins c'est vraiment de très
très gros butin chaque fois de prendre
plus d'une 4 4 minutes en moyenne
on a même vu hier le président pinera
faire une prestation pitoyable sur sûre
quand il est allé donner c'est ses
bulletins de vote
il ya même comment je vais recommander
de la ilaha illa lamy sa longue sur le
sur le lait les papiers qui permet de
fermer le bilan des votes devant tout le
monde donc c'est une élection qui va
être difficile ils sont donc attendues
la nuit prochaine autour de minuit merci
beaucoup pour votre décryptage aurait la
main je rappelle que vous êtes fondateur
du blog france chili